I rearranged all the furniture in my
house today which is how you can tell
that I had a lot of work I should have
done today because I avoided that work
by rearranging all of the furniture in
my house today
hey guys grace Helbig here if you didn't
know if you sincerely didn't know I'm
really happy to have you here and that's
not just lip service hey-oh I don't even
know if this is my shirt Mondays on this
channel are usually reserved for not to
date which is my audio and video podcast
if you are so inclined to check it out
please go on iTunes or SoundCloud you
can listen to all the previous episodes
that we've had or you can look back on
this channel and see all of the
challenge videos that I've done with all
the guests of the podcast however this
week we're taking a quick break we'll be
back next week
don't worry or do worry if you need to
get worry out of your system do it in
the meantime I thought I would do a Q&A
with you guys because those are
difficult and groundbreaking pieces of
content and I haven't done them for a
while so let's do it I went on my
Facebook page if you are not following
me on Facebook you should you don't have
to but it would be cool and ask you guys
for questions for me to answer and I've
chosen a bunch of them so let's get into
getting to know each other on the
mutually surface level do you miss New
York I do I do miss the pace of New York
and I miss the excitement of New York
there's like two weeks every fall in two
weeks every spring that the weather is
absolutely perfect and then before and
after those two weeks it's just a shame
awful but I don't miss the paranoia of
everything I touch being coated in six
layers of human fecal matter what's your
favorite thing about VidCon one of my
favorite things about VidCon is that we
all try to represent the best version of
ourselves everyone tries to be really
clean I'm right now trying to pick out
clothes that I want to bring down to
VidCon with me it feels a lot like prom
everyone looks like the after on a
makeover show and that's one of my
favorite things is to see how everyone
chooses to present themselves in a
physical way why is there no VidCon red
carpet
want to do a big gun fashion review
should I do a big gun fashion review
I'll take this silence as a maybe ever
wanna come to Sweden
based on that emoji that I'm pretty sure
as a smiley face with a double chin yes
what was the last song you listened to I
listened to out of the woods by Taylor
Swift I really like that song that's it
what do you like in the sandwich I like
my sandwiches like I like my significant
others BLT beautiful loving Tomatoes
skirt jam apricot right what's the worst
tip you give to someone with diarrhea
any tip let them get to a bathroom don't
stop them and make them listen to your
tips what is your latest obsession
must-haves oh my god squatty potty it
basically is the step stool that fits
around your toilet that your feet go on
because as human beings we are meant to
[ __ ] like cavemen with our legs elevated
and trust me this makes you [ __ ] like a
caveman favorite dog Instagram where is
it where is it Rene Charles NYC this is
a French Bulldog obviously one the
photos are great the beautiful photo to
the captions are the best I don't even
want to spoil it just go Rene Charles
and I see if you like fun fish we're
okay what does fish mean this is I'm
looking it up short for [ __ ] but using
a playful sort of way not intended to be
hurtful and often used between friends
example oMG fish you took forever to
call me back oh now back to the question
at hand [ __ ] we're fish what fish fish
I need more info fish fish fish fish
saying fish makes me feel like I'm drunk
trying to say the word [ __ ] fine the
jargon is fun so are you that's what I'm
trying to figure out Sebastian who are
you well gonna be a season 2 of the
grace Helbig show like my favorite party
game
I'm in limbo
right now I'll let you know how can i
impress a girl I like continue to become
the-best-version-of-yourself and if
they're not impressed
then bish bye Felicia
did I do it Internet what is your
favorite place in the world my favorite
place in the world is my own home at
night when I know I don't have to wake
up early and I don't have anything that
I need to do work wise but there are a
few episodes of The Real Housewives that
I haven't watched yet and a bottle of
vodka in a freezer
have you asked Siri what 0/0 is I
haven't done this yet but I know this is
a thing because the internet had it
trending on it all of it so I'm gonna do
it now anyway here's the first question
how should I ask Siri anything Siri what
is 0/0 imagine that you have zero
cookies and you split them evenly among
zero friends how many cookies does each
person get see it doesn't make sense and
Cookie Monster's said that there are no
cookies and you are sad that you have no
friends
well that was delightful Thank You
internet for yet another great
suggestion well there you go there are
some of my age to your cues I hope that
you enjoyed this on any level and if you
did give this a thumbs up you know what
they say if you see something say
something
I'm saying if you feel something thumbs
up this so it's actually not related at
all to that phrase and don't forget to
subscribe to this channel to make sure
that you don't have to seek out videos I
will seek you out with my video it's
like the girlfriend that you wished
would take a chill pill nope subscribe
for lack of chill pills
I don't know based on this decor you
might think I have amnesia I can't
remember my name or what it starts with
but now just I'm just vain